المقابل قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو ان
الانتصار في العمليه العسكريه الروسيه امر
لا مفر منه
عبر الفيديو لتهنئه افراد القوات الروسيه
القوات المسلحه الروسيه بمناسبه راس السنه
الجديده
بالحرب وقدموا اصدقاء
جنودنا ان انتصارنا مثل قدوم العام الجديد
نظام الينا الان من قسطنطينيه مراسل
الجزيره عمر الحاج وايضا من موسكو مدير
مكتب الجزيره زورشه وج اهلا بكما لعلي
يبدا بك اذا هذه تصريحات الاخيره له
الشويغو يؤكد فيها بان النصر في اوكرانيا
تاكد بان موسكو تحتاج لي التعبئه من جديد
قالت انها لا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار تلك
التصريحات وانا تتعرض لحرب الاعلاميه
والجانب الروسي على مدى اسابيع نفى ان
يكون هناك اي خطوه او اي خطه لاعلان جديده
وانا ما قامت به روسيا يكفي للان وان وان
تقريبا نصف من تم استدعائهم للتعبئه لم
يلتحقوا لحد الان بالجبهه وانما موجودين
بالقطاعات على العسكريه بعيدا عن
التصريحات همم
المتناوله من قبل الطرفين هنا في روسيا
ربما التركيز لدرجه الاولى همم الان على
تصريحات اخرى في جانب سياسي وهي مهمه جدا
بعيدا عن اتهامات كل طرف الاخر بانجازاته
العسكريه حيث اتهمت موسكو فعليا شركائها
في ما يعرف باتفاق الكذب وهذا ما صدر
اليوم عن نائب رئيس مجلس الاتحاد الروسي
تعليقا على اعترافات الرئيس الفرنسي
السابق فرنسا اون لاين التي قال فيها ان
اتفاقيه مينسكا لتسويه في اوكرانيا كانت
مجرده محاوله لكسب الوقت من اجل تقويه
الجيش الاوكراني وهو كرر فعليا بعد ايام
قليله تصريحات مماثله لشركه الاخرى في
اتفاقيات ميسكو ايها المستشاره الالمانيه
انجل ميركل بالنسبه
لموسكو همم اعتبرت ان هذا همم اعتراف همم
الكذب والخداع التاريخي وثيقه همم التاريخ
وانها كانت تعتقد هذا على الانسان نائب
رئيس مجلس الاتحاد الروسي انها تعرف كانت
انا همم الاوروبيون لا يريدون التفاوض ولا
يريدون سوى همم هزيمته روسيا هذا من ناحيه
من ناحيه ثانيه اليوم سفيان روسيا تدخل في
عطله عطله راس السنه وهي الم الرئيسيه
وبالتالي تتراجع التصريحات كما هو المعتاد
في اليوم الاخير من العام وبدايه العامه
الجديد من المتوقع ان تكون هناك كلمه
تهنئه هذه الرئيس الروسي وبلاد ماربو تسع
يتطرق بها بدون شك
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ولكن ضمن العناوين العريضه وليس باي
تفاصيل او خطط للمستقبل سوى تلك التي
تتحدث عن انتصار روسي الى مطار منه على
غرار ما قاله شيكو